so we as I said we're going to be
talking about the speech as far as the
Shadow Chancellor is concerned things he
talked about were a whole review of the
taxation system talked also about the
Robin Hood Tax which means companies
like Vodafone and Starbucks are they
paying enough tax and will they have to
pay more he also appealed to others of
the party who had decided that when mr.
Corbyn became the leader of the Labour
Party that they would instead return to
the back benches let's get some reaction
to the Shadow Chancellor speech at the
conference Newports deputy political
editor of the Sun Guardian columnist
Owen Jones joining us from conference in
Brighton hello to you Jennifer I think
it's fair to say both sides of the
political spectrum for our viewers right
there what were the headlines for you
two and Steve you first I think John
McDonald undersold himself when he said
it'd be boring it was definitely very
polite for someone who jokes about
assassinating political leaders in the
past was very polished but slightly
pie-in-the-sky there was some very
radical thinking talking about
intervening when the Bank of England
inviting the governor for a chat very
threatening language talking about
putting a Rakhi at the depart for
business basically talking about a
blizzard of red tape and a blizzard of
state intervention be very interesting
to see what the elektra actually feel
about it okay well I think it's 33 cap
he caps off the jokes is no comedian
Jonathan Ollie captain's dead sir
to the detail I think what was good as
he took on the economic record of the
Conservatives labour failed to do that
George Osborne promised to wipe out the
deficit in Wahb Parliament it didn't
even get through half added more debt
than every Labour government put
together a Productivity crisis so bad in
this country that French workers took
every Friday off that country would
still be more productive than this
country longest fall in living standards
for workers since the 19th century we
haven't really had that taken on but
what was more interesting and I think
this is important is they're not just
talking about low income people that you
know about people at the bottom that's
what makes the you know that the the
heart of the left being faster fighting
for people in poverty homeless people
and so on
they were directly pitching for middle
income and middle class people they're
talking about self employed people in
lack security and the support that the
state can give to them
and I'm also talking about I guess I
kind of investing in infrastructure and
learning from countries like Germany we
have in public investment banks to
support the industries of the future and
I think you know it might sound radical
in this country but if he goes to Angela
Merkel's right-wing led
Germany those sorts of policies are
actually just very mainstream and
common-sense what he definitely talks
about the middle class because he I
think he wants to tax them a lot more
and in fact he talks about the rich
because he talked about trying to take
more off them it's just about how the
sums that up and it's not just about the
electorate it's also about his own party
you have to remember that John McDonough
and Jeremy Corbyn this is anti austerity
is that that's the main thing for them I
probably think I would agree with that
this was the big platform where these
three pounders swarmed to lay but
they're trying at this anti austerity
message into the Labour Party forget try
and forget Syria this is what they're
all about
but it's convincing the party Caroline
Flint for example earlier this summer
said some benefits some people benefit
me to kick up the arse I just come from
a fringe meeting where Polly Billington
said a very similar thing and crucially
John Healy who was at the same French
meeting reminding people that labor have
to win 96 seats of the 2020 election off
the Tories have a majority of one how
this message goes down in places like
thorak and then Eaton will be crucial I
think talking about politicians talking
about kicking benefit claims that the
else I think none of them have actually
said that and I think if they use that
language about their about low paid work
is supermarket workers currently half of
that in work benefits taken away that
would be very unfortunate because this
government's cutting support for low
paid supermarket workers cleaners and so
on and actually the point I think you
know I think to be fair you know you
were journalists your political
journalists and it's fair to say what he
actually said in the speech which was he
does want to take on the deficit and
close the deficit that just not on the
backs of low income and middle income
people and that they they are gonna take
on the deficit in that way and actually
rather than clobbering middle-class
people indeed middle-income people with
taxes what if it was more interesting is
they're talking about the fact that big
corporations aren't paying taxes now if
you go to small businesses like these
are little cafes there's some founder
the front here in Brighton
they have to pay all their taxes they
don't have accountancy firms sent to the
Treasury to help draw tax laws and then
tell their clients how to get around
them and that's about being on the side
of small businesses paying their way
contributing and big companies that
benefit from the state from
infrastructure from lots and lots of
subsidies and and support from the state
which they're now
a view that actually it's about
priorities and that's what it politics
isn't it's about priorities that's
standing up for low-income middle-income
working-class and middle-class people
rather than the people who are very much
sure and I think I think you'll find I
mean we would be in favor of it we've
talked a lot about people looking
Starbucks for example Amazon and George
Osborne himself has talked about text in
these companies more and trying to do
what they can to bring more tax in from
these companies you know it's but it's
not just its small business as well that
worried about this engineering employers
Federation I've already prevailed quite
in favor of what a lot of what they're
Miliband was talking about before the
election and they've already come up
with a statement since John McDonnell
sat down talking about worrying about
some of the rhetoric worrying about the
language and which is talking about
business I mean chocolate on obviously
is going to talk about balancing the
books but there wasn't much detail on
how he would cut a lot more detail how's
your question though now you listen you
want to stand up you say for small
businesses and self-employed people a
million self-employed people are not
having their tax credits at cut by this
government they're people who like
pensions paid sick leave paid maternity
leave and 85 percent of them don't
employ anyone but themselves they have
very insecure lives they like
independence they like being their own
boss but they often don't have the
support all the workers have if they're
proposing to support small businesses by
freezing business rates by supporting
them in Social Security and opposing
cuts the tax credit is as tax rates read
the self-employed some yes any support
we're a big supporter of small miss with
a big support and balance in the books
they try and help them do you think we
should freeze business rates like the
labial situation definitely tackle
business rate so maybe if I was coming
out as oh he's talking so loudly we
should definitely take a business where
you're very clear there's always the
point and when I was some business head
as we talked about business rates a lot
something has to happen there but it
needs to be a credible approach I think
it needs to be an all-round thing John
McDonnell today was promised in the
world he said another world is possible
but it might not be possible in the real
world well you say another world is
possible
you know you know British people
throughout history have been full of
optimism they have and determination and
idealism and that's why we have bill
actually in lots of ways a great country
lots of problems with the country but I
think you saw you know you sell the
country sure when you talk about someone
who's actually suggesting actually we
can have a vision of a different Britain
this is how we can do it well tax people
at the top more to support middle-income
and low-income people will balance the
books but in a fair and just way will
invest in the industries of the future
that's another world that is possible
and will tell you how it's possible you
get this kind of oh stop this
pie-in-the-sky idealism we've got a cot
support fit low-paid supermarket work
you support cutting I mean that cutting
tax credits for low pay T from our I
support everyone did you like it yeah
just before we let you go you both need
to have just going to talk guys with
being potty mouth politico's well he
started in there's always a sudden that
low ease of standard of political debate
ingesting injecting these sorts of you
know so the meaning words obviously I'm
so sorry okay off you go : you see you
soon thanks a lot okay thank you very
much yeah